le look 1 nous a plus vraiment parce que
la sorge chalandon parle vraiment de son
père et son père est un vrai acteur du
livre habituellement le l'image du père
est toujours présent dans tous les
livres qu'il ait pu faire
mais là cette fois ci on voit vraiment
quelle a été la vie de sorj chalandon 20
ans imagine plutôt parce que la barrière
entre le réel et la fiction n'est pas
bien et assez ténue donc on sait pas
vraiment où aller placer le curseur
mais en tout état de cause on sait que
voilà son père était un affabulateur un
misanthrope et qu'il battait en plus sa
femme et ses et son enfant donc voilà
donc là c'est par la vision d'un enfant
de 13 ans que
sorj chalandon va donc décrire comme en
été et quelle vie il a eu et quelle
relation finalement il a il a essayé de
tisser avec ce père qui était violent
que ce soit avec sa mère comme avec lui
donc cet enfant de 13 ans à une vie
n'est pas vraiment sympa c'est dans les
années 60 en plein moment où l'oiseau
asc vie est belle avec l'algérie
française
donc c'est pas une bonne période non
plus pour la pour la france et pour la
société donc voilà on toute l'attention
ressurgit aussi dans le livre
donc il ya des moments qui sont assez
rude assez violent enfin tout au kiss ou
qui sont égrenées comme ça à travers le
livre mais il ya aussi des passages qui
nous permette un peu de reprendre notre
souffle
c'est aussi ça qui permet de voilà de de
s'aérer aussi un peu parce que c'est
vraiment qu'un récit très grave avec des
des brutalités sur des enfants ou sur sa
femme
et voilà ceux typiquement tu cette
petite pigmentation la de moments de
détente nous permettent aussi d'avoir
une finalement une lecture un peu plus
fluide deux ouvrages et plus agréable ce
que j'ai vraiment retenu mois de ce
livret qui est vraiment important c'est
que le lien qui unit un fils vers son
père et l'amour qui peut mettre dans ce
lien et dense est dans cette liaison
c'est que malgré ce qui peut se passer
ou ce qui peut ce qu'ils peuvent les
épreuves qu'ils peuvent traverser durant
toute toute leur vie c'est qu'il restera
toujours présente finalement l'amour
quoi qui se passe est plus fort que le
reste est que le lien qui unit le fils
au père va rester présents tout au long
de sa vie dans ce roman jeanne benameur
nous fait le portrait d'un jeune homme
un trentenaire qui se prénomme etienne
c'est un photographe de guerre
donc il passe sa vie à aller toujours
plus loin dans d autres de plus en plus
violente
jusqu'au jour où il est enlevé séquestré
le roman débute par la libération
détiennent son retour à sa son village
natal il va y retrouver sa mère son
meilleur ami une amie d'enfance et il va
falloir qu'il s'acclimate à nouveau à ce
cocon familial qui est très douillet et
puis en même temps il a vécu des choses
tellement dur que c'est assez complexe
pour lui de se réintégrer d'accepter les
petits bonheurs de la vie et d'oublier
tout ça que toute cette chose si la fin
de tout ce passé sinon on se rend compte
en fait au fur et à mesure du roman que
lui il a été otage on comprend très bien
à quel point ça peut être difficile etc
mais chaque personnage que nous décrit
jeanne benameur et également otages deux
des choses de la vie de son quotidien et
c'est à elle nous fait nous poser la
question de ce n'est pas tous otage de
quelque chose ou de quelqu'un c'est ça
qui est intéressant est ce qui est très
bien ce qui est très réussie dans ce
roman de jeanne benameur et ce qui est
le cas pour les ses précédents romans
c'est que elle a beau nous raconter des
choses absolument atroce des cas de vie
difficiles des rien des choses un peu
lourde
elle émet une telle poésie que ça pèse
un peu tout ce tous pathos et ça en fait
finalement euros moins lumineux en fait
c'est l'histoire de
d'un gang improbable qui se forment en
fait au sein d'une maison de retraite
donc il ya une infirmière il ya deux
pensionnaires il ya le mézo l'homme de
maison et donc on va suivre en fait les
pérégrinations de ce gang tout au tout
au long de la france et est tout au long
d'un cheminement
durant un été en fait tout la canicule à
sommes totalement la france est donc ce
gang là va se faire braqueur de
supermarchés et pour prendre des
brumisateurs et des bouteilles d'eau et
donc venir donner un peu de fraîcheur à
toutes ces maisons de retraite là qui
sont sous la canicule mais ils vont pas
donner uniquement de la fraîcheur ils
vont aussi donner de l'espoir à tous ces
petits vieux là qui sont dans les
maisons de retraite et donc ils vont
comme ça ce cheminot tout au lond tout
au long d'un parcours initiatique mais
qui voilà qui va donner un peu d'espoir
aux gens et durant cet été là où
vraiment tout le monde est un peu à peu
gentil par la chaleur les gens vont
reprendre un peu d'espoir il ya un
mouvement qui va se créer derrière
derrière ce gang de pieds nickelés et
qui va commencer à monter en flèche
et voilà c'est donc cette histoire-là de
de fraîcheur mais aussi de de relations
vis-à-vis de la société de relations
vis-à-vis des intempéries qui est qu'on
peut avoir dans la vie mais que
finalement il faut pas par la
résignation n'est pas obligatoire et que
souvent il ya des possibilités de
d'avoir un une perspective de sortie
freedom oliver est une jeune femme qui
bénéficie du programme de protection des
témoins et le fbi lui a gentiment offert
de travailler dans un bar miteux au fin
fond de l'oregon elle a beaucoup de
choses à oublier elle a le temps pour y
penser à elle voit notamment oublier le
fait qu'elle a assassiné son mari qui
était un flic considéré comme héroïque
par toute sa famille et ses proches et
ses collègues elle doit également
oublier l'abandon de ses enfants du fait
de son incarcération puis de sa
protection de témoins mais
malheureusement à la beauce noyé dans
l'alcool et dans les médicaments elle va
pas pouvoir oublier tout ça parce que
son ancienne belle famille la retrouve
et dans le même temps elle apprend dans
les médias que sa fille a été enlevée et
à travers ce roman à une description
d'une amérique alors à la fois très
sombre dans cette oregon où il pleut
souvent il se passe pas grand chose et
très lumineuse parce qu'il ya des
passages à san francisco des moments
très beau c'est un roman on a tous
toutes les caractéristiques du grand
roman et du grand polar américain on a
des armes à feu à foison nains pasteur
fou de dieu qui tente de monter une
secte on a des des voitures qui crissent
dans les virages soit voilà c'est
vraiment un très très bon polar
on s'attache à cette femme alors que
vraiment il n'ya pas de quoi et on n'a
qu'une envie c'est qu'elle qu'elle
retrouve sa fille et qu'elle échappe à
sa belle famille mais jaxx miller va un
peu lui complique il lui compliquer la
tâche